- All right, everybody.
It is time for Drew's News.
When life flattens your
tires, we'll pump 'em back up
with that good news air. (mimics air pump)
(Ross laughs)
Well, with me at the desk
is my dearest friend,
who I know could always change any tire,
it's Ross Matthews.
(audience applauds)
- No, call a different friend.
(Ross mimics laser gun)
- I know.
- I couldn't do that.
- Do you keep a jack in your car?
- I don't even know if
I keep a jack in my,
sorry, what's a jack?
I don't know.
(audience laughs)
My dad was a mechanic
and you would've thought
that he would've taught
me how to change a tire
and maybe he tried, but
I was not interested.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
(audience applauds)
- Okay, Ross, your story.
- Well, here's a fun story.
A really fun one.
There's a brand new job
opening up at Buckingham Palace
and Drew Barrymore,
I feel like you might need
to apply for this one.
Apartment Therapy reports The
Queen is hiring a decorator.
She wants to redecorate
the entire Royal household
room by room.
So she's, she's looking for someone
with a passion for
historic buildings, check.
Good communication skills, check, check.
And a natural team player,
check, check, check.
The job pays $40,000 a year.
It has full benefits and a pension
and you get 33 days off a year.
(audience gasp and applaud)
All right.
So Madam, is this a job you'd want?
And what would you do with it?
- I love designing so much
(audience applauds)
- [Ross] You've got a great aesthetic.
- I wanna get her one of those
neon signs above her bed.
That just says, "Yas Queen"
(they laugh)
I gotta figure it out.
- I love that.
- Yeah. Right.
- But who would not want
to work as a designer?
You're out there making
people's spaces brighter
and happier places for them to be.
Queen or no Queen, I'm in.
- Yeah, I think so too.
And I think it's time for
the whole Royal family.
They need a little refresh
on everything, right?
So let's start with a little decor.
(audience applauds)
- Well, this is
a story I found and I thought,
"Oh, I have to bring this to the desk."
Okay, so attention, New Yorkers.
We are officially the first
city where this is happening.
Uber is joining forces with Yellow Cabs.
The New York Times reports
that starting this spring
Uber will allow you to order
a yellow taxi on their app.
They're teaming up with the
two apps that already exist
for Yellow Cab, Curb and CMT.
And if you order a Yellow Cab on Uber,
you'll pay Uber rates,
including surge prices.
- Wah-wah.
- What do you think?
- Well, I think we have to,
they have to make this kind of change,
'cause it's a brand new world.
I just have to say
as somebody with a proud 4.89 Uber rating.
I hope that this doesn't affect it,
because I'm really proud of that.
I do have to say, I am.
(audience applauds)
4.89 is good.
- I don't know what my Uber rating is.
I know that I'm a happy passenger.
- Yeah.
- But I feel like
I'm also a late to get
downstairs passenger.
- Oh, that's gonna affect your score.
4.89. That means I'm
polite, I'm courteous.
I talk, but I don't over talk. (laughs)
- Do you choose the talk to
me or don't talk to me button?
- I let them figure it out.
You know what I mean?
- So you say "Yes, I allow conversation."
- Express yourself through Uber.
- Okay, How many hands,
show raise of hands say no to conversation
on your Uber app?
Right there. Proud, I love it.
I'm sorry.
Aren't you glad you raised your hand now?
Okay, why do you do it?
- [Lady] I talk about this
all the time to my coworkers,
because I work overnight shifts
and I just feel like
that's a no conversation.
Like, it's acceptable.
It should be acceptable.
- Yeah.
- Yes, to me.
- And you like that option?
(audience applauds)
- I love that.
I like your approach.
(bright music)